okay peyton list we are here to talk
cobra kai season 3
spoilers and this show is so fantastic i
i think it's the best like of all the
reboots and resurgences of things we've
seen
and i'm just curious from your
perspective because we have seen a lot
of reboots resurgences and they don't
always
work what do you think it is about cobra
kai that makes it
so special oh well
i really feel like i cannot take any
credit for for
all of that for the reason it works but
i think that um
our creators of cobra kai of the series
and the writers john josh and hayden
they were the biggest karate kid fans
and um they met with ralph and billy
and they all kind of came up with this
concept together
and um they just i feel like they throw
so many easter eggs in and like pay
homage to the original films and
um they are fans so i feel like they
know what they would want to see and
since they are such big fans i feel like
it translates
to the original karate kid fans and it
just works um
and i think also flipping the roles you
know for billy and ralph
and um yeah just i feel like
taking billy's character and humbling
him and uh
where he is now in his life is it all
just really works
you know i was thinking about tori a lot
too and i'm like at first i thought
that miguel and robbie were kind of the
johnny daniel but now it's like
i feel like it's tori and sam really
so do you feel like tori is kind of a
johnny character do you think she's kind
of misunderstood
that's interesting that you say that
because i've been hearing that theory
more and more
and that is something i love about the
show is that there are so many different
fan theories and conspiracies and you
could just go down a rabbit hole of
reading and i actually
and even when tori's name was
accidentally schwarber online
not even sure how that happened i just
was laughing because of the
like rumors that start flying along with
that
but um i do think that tory is
misunderstood i think she's dealt with a
lot in her life
and um yes she doesn't always
uh you know re respond the way she
should but i do think just like
johnny she she is um she has gone
through a lot and has had to fight for a
lot in her life
and i do think she means well
at the end of the day i i do think
they're she that she is a good person
maybe it's because i play her and i see
where she's coming from
but yeah she's troubled you know she's
really
have great guidance in her life which is
why she ends up
you know kris is really the only adult
in her life that's taken her
in and tried to help her i think that's
one of the things the show does so well
is like
yes there are villains but they don't
think they're villains and then you'll
kind of like see their perspective
like this shows like humanize the hell
out of crease which i never thought we
would see
i know i agree the season's seeing his
his crease's backstory and young chris
and him and
i i really did like find this new love
for him
um but yeah they really do a great job
of that of
what i love is everyone has their
favorite and
it could be different like a whole a
whole family can sit down for dinner and
have a debate about who their favorite
and who their least favorite is
and like my family does that so i think
that's a really cool aspect to the show
so the season ends with torrey very much
aligned with kris
do you think kris is the right sensei
for her
i do not think crease is the right
sentence for corey i really don't
i mean even in season three when he
when he tells her that you know miguel
and sam are back together
you can just tell he's trying to start
something there i feel like
the whole fight the whole you know
christmas party fight is kind of
crease's fault
and it starts from him just sort of
wanting to just
throw you know fuel the fire and
i don't i think tory has enough fire as
it is and i prom
miyagi would probably be a good place
for tori honestly to learn some balance
to find peace
and uh some of mr miyagi's teachings
would probably be
a good idea seeing johnny and daniel put
their differences aside and team up in
the finale
um was amazing how did you react when
you
read that or found that out oh
i was pretty mind blown by every script
i feel like the writers always
um surprised me even yeah i was shocked
by that i think what i was
most shocked by was ally's return and
yeah also just the fact that johnny and
daniel are finally getting along
i think yeah that was pretty
mind-blowing for me
we have to talk about that spectacular
christmas showdown that you just
mentioned
what was it like filming that because i
think that was probably the most like
intense in terms of stunt choreography
that we've seen so far
yeah the writers kept warning me they
were like you know you better you better
keep training because
episode 10 the finale it's gonna be
crazy like numchucks
get ready and um yeah that
really was intense and at the end of
season two in the finale in the school
we did a oner we did this big take where
it was just one fluid take in the
hallway and we did that again in the
christmas episode
and it was all of us practicing at the
same time
and in this big scene around the entire
house
and if one of us messes up then we've
ruined the take for everyone and there
are some people getting slammed
and thrown and people are being hard on
their bodies you know and
um it's super physical and
you know we there really couldn't be any
cuts or any mess-ups so i think there
was that
pressure of which for me is good because
knowing that other people you know they
have things at stake and if i mess up
it's
messing up with the whole team i think
that that just adds so much energy and
whenever we would
finish those takes we would all just be
screaming and clapping and just so
excited about the whole thing
so um i think that energy
is is really fun but also you know it's
it's a little bit more of a challenge
right i don't know what your karate
background is are you like do you
actively take karate now or did you take
it before
i never my life thought i'd be taking
karate but now
here i am uh about to go into training
every day
uh leading up to season four but
yeah i've just been i have been taking
uh karate and
trying to just learn it on my own while
i'm at home
um which is what billy and ralph do like
they're so good
so they've really inspired me um because
ever since the karate kid they've been
doing it
and they have such a love for it and i
think all the kids on the show
are inspired by them and they really
i mean they really do feel like our real
senseis in life what's your favorite
movie of the franchise do you have one
the first one the first karate kid so
good
i am i grew up a big next karate kid fan
so i'm a big hillary small person what
do you think the chances are that we
could get
hillary swank in the show i feel like
that has to happen oh
i do too i i want that i mean i feel
like we've set the bar so high with this
last season
that i just i want everyone to come back
and reprise the rules
but i have no idea i haven't heard
anything about it thank god because it's
hard for me to keep secrets
yeah but i think that would be so epic
if
she came in i love her i wonder if she's
seen it or watches the show i wonder
i wonder i don't know it'd be hard for
me like i
i feel like i would watch it because she
could come in i think her name was julie
she could come in she could be like tori
get out of there with chris let me take
me over to miyagi
save me i think i did meet her once when
i was a kid
in new york acting she came into a
trailer
that during while i was in hair makeup i
think she was a producer on the movie so
i've seen her once before
i feel like you've met everyone like i
was looking at your imdb
b credits and i was like you've been in
everything like
27 dresses one of my favorite movies of
all time just
peyton list hanging out just because i
was
eight or nine years old and i would play
like the younger version of every blonde
that was how i got my start like i
played the young catherine heigl and the
young kate hudson
and um so when i finally had a younger
version of myself
i was like whoa i am no longer
younger blonde of everyone else who is
someone you would like to have more
scenes with in season four
i don't really have many scenes with uh
with ralph and the miyagi doe
people so be fun to have some scenes
with the lyricists i don't know how they
make that happen
but um yeah i would i would like to
to interact with ralph a little bit more
yeah that'd be good
who would you like to see tori fight in
the all valley
i think i'd like to see her fight hawk
because now i feel like she has this
sort of
um they have this big rivalry because he
left
cobra kai and uh i think loyalty is a
big thing
to everyone at cobra kai and so that
i think there would be a lot of of um
you know history there yeah we have one
fight to watch
tori and robbie i'm very invested in now
because they keep stealing glances at
each other
and i'm into it because they're kind of
similar
like how do you feel like they would
fare as a couple
i think it would either be you ship it
really yeah i mean i think it's probably
kind of
like toxic but i kind of ship it that
was kind of my thought i was like
it could go you know two two ways i do
think that
robbie and sam were good for each other
um
so maybe robbie could be a good
influence on tori uh
i i think they're they're cute together
i think that you know
tori kind of needs to hang up the miguel
towel sadly
i think uh she needs to let him let him
go
yeah you know robbie and tori can relate
on a lot
i feel like they've you know they've had
to fight for themselves and
they've had a little bit rougher
definitely
tori and sam's rivalry is uh is gonna
heat up but i'm
i'm kind of rooting for them to like
team up someday like daniel and johnny
what do you think it would take for
those two to come together i
i was saying to someone i was like you
know after season two and this school
fight
i thought that was where the writers
could come back you know season three
they could have tori come back
and um maybe her and sam can make amends
but
when they decided to just go the
opposite way
they just kept committing to the rivalry
and everything else i was like
this is gonna be harder to come back
from so
i really don't know how we come back
from that something something huge would
have to happen and i just don't know if
i see it happening
you know sometimes with those people in
life that you just never
you're never gonna be friends with and
that's kind of how i see them
but i also don't know because the
writers always shocked me so
true true well you kind of touched on
this but there's so many theories
floating around about the show
do you have a favorite theory about tori
that you've read
i think for a little while there when
people thought she might be ally's
daughter
i thought that was a really fun theory
and i wanted to be true so bad
um that was my favorite one i've read
also um
yeah i mean just the the related ones i
think are yeah
i was just reading one cause like chris
calls what we think is terry silver at
the end of the season and then people
a couple people said they think that
terry silver might be your dad
whoa i have not heard that one yet
yeah what do you think of that i think
that would be epic
it would make sense why chris is like so
invested in tory if it's like his like
buddy's daughter no see everyone that
watches the show i mean
they're on it that is that's an
interesting one
i would really like that i like that no
like i like it too i read it today so
i'm still processing that one but i like
it
i like it yeah i love how much research
you've done by the way
karate in general this does it does a
lot for people for their body their soul
their mind
what has being a part of cobra kai the
series done for you
it has it has changed
my life honestly like even playing tori
i've been in
she she is so different from me but i've
been so inspired from her
and by learning self-defense and and
learning how to fight i think it's
really
um it's really empowering and i feel
like everyone should do it at some point
in their life
it's um yeah i i i'm like
the karate kid has changed my life what
in the world love it
do you have a dream role that you want
to
hit in the next i don't know five years
or something
i think i didn't realize how much i
would love to do action
and i and how much i love getting to do
the stunt work and everything else um
getting to do a movie where i where i
fight more and
and get to do more scents would be uh
would be a dream you guys
got renewed for season four um
have you are you filming yet are you
filming soon uh yeah we're about to
start filming
very soon i i don't even know exactly
when all i know is that i'm going to
atlanta
uh in the next couple weeks and then we
start training
so how long do you foresee the show
going for do you feel like it's like
many more seasons to go
i feel like with the writers we have
they can really take it as long as they
want
and with the amount of characters they
have and everything else but
i have no idea but i i
i mean i feel like they would never run
out of of things
to do i mean heck they brought it back
from you know 30 years
so i bet they could keep it going that's
all the questions i have you're so
amazing to talk to
and oh my gosh likewise i feel like i
was talking to a friend because you know
so much
about the about the show it was so fun